la ville de new york accueille la parade
mondial de la fierté
un événement pour se souvenir du chemin
parcouru depuis la nuit du 28 au 29 juin
1969 une descente dans un bar de
greenwich village le stonewall inn a
marqué le début de la lutte pour les
droits civiques des personnes
homosexuelles
cinquante ans plus tard la répression a
cédé la place à la fierté
je suis profondément fier d'être gay est
libre de mon choix grâce à ce tournoi où
j'ai pu me marier je me souviens d'un
temps où mes amis ont été tabassés et
persécutés
la bataille n'est pas finie pour autant
les choses ont changé pour le mieux
je suis reconnaissant à la société qui a
permis que nos droits soient respectés
à new york des millions de personnes
sont attendues pour la parade qui se
tiendra dimanche pour clôturer plusieurs
jours de célébrations mois bill de
blasio maire de new york déclare le
vendredi 28 juin 2010 9 jours de
stonewall ailleurs dans le monde
des marches des fiertés se tiennent tout
au long de la semaine
à paris des milliers de personnes ont
bravé la canicule pour se réunir à
montparnasse
un cortège festif mais ailleurs dans le
monde
la situation est loin d'être rose
l'homosexualité est condamnés parfois à
la peine capitale ou à la prison à
perpétuité
ici à son kayak radio canada montréal